man show me something for week eight and
peter i have a mark a mike mccarthy
related trivia question for you
mike mccarthy's brother
coached which nfl starting quarterback
when he was an 8th grade basketball
player
ben denucci
ding there you go that's correct
mike do you know why you asked that
question because you and i in the last
break both looked up bendanucci's
wikipedia page and we saw that about ben
dinucci
actually i asked the question just
because it was in the sheet i didn't
look up the wikipedia page for better
you get the first you get the first pick
in the show me something draft who you
got
show me something cam newton you have
been properly penitent
over the last couple of weeks
and you've taken it all on your
shoulders and good for you that's what a
leader does the guy's in your locker
room everybody tells me the guys in that
locker room love cam newton he's been
great
now he's just got to play great new
england patriots go to buffalo their
season on the line they haven't been
three games under 500
since the teddy roosevelt administration
i was ready for some scintillating fact
i could share with friends and relatives
but no no
no you were exaggerating
i thought it was very telling this week
when cam newton said on weei that yes
you don't want the coaches to be upset
with you but the players talk and he's
trying to keep the respect of the locker
room this is his chance to do it next
one for me first one for me technically
show me something ben denucci let's
start right there this is your chance
now tony romo was a guy who was
undrafted but he was able to develop for
several seasons able to practice able to
show bill parcells something before he
was put into a game denucci no
off-season program limited reps denucci
gets a chance to save the cowboys season
at least for now
by beating the eagles and thrusting
dallas into first place and it was also
a tony romo debut on sunday night
football back in 2006 the first year of
nbc's sunday night football all right
who else you got peter
but mike mike and i'm going to remind
you more than any team in football in
this century the dallas cowboys have a
history
of the nobodies rising up and being
great at that position undrafted tony
romo uh and then dak prescott the 135th
pick in the draft after they lose out on
paxton lynch and the immortal conor cook
they have to settle for for uh dak
prescott so in my opinion the stage is
set it'll be a great great story for ben
dinucci all right
i hate to just dominate this list with
quarterbacks
show me something to atanga veloa
your coach
benched a 70 quarterback
who's won two weeks in a row by 26
points at san francisco
and then by 24 points against the
hapless jets that quarterback got
benched for you
so you can't come out and lay an egg
against the los angeles rams you've got
to figure out how to beat aaron donald i
don't care how great he is and i don't
care how good that pass rush is
pressure right away against the guy but
i think he'll handle it mike because
he's every game he's played hasn't he
played almost every game when you've got
the hot breath of nick saban down your
neck
i mean he is in i think he's in a good
position to succeed but that doesn't
mean there isn't a lot of pressure on
him on sunday against the los angeles
rams
yeah adding to the pressure joe burrow
the first pick justin herbert the sixth
pick both have looked great so far this
year let's see if tua looks as great as
they do next one for me show me
something le'veon bell you got what you
wanted you got out of new york you're in
kansas city limited use that first game
six carries 39 yards at denver now
you're going against the jets show me
that you got that fire show me that you
got that passion show me that you still
have that ability and show the jets all
at the same time so let's see what
le'veon bell can do this weekend peter
show me something new orleans saints
offensive line okay so the saints have
only allowed eight sacks so far this
year in six games that's fantastic
but this week will be the sternest test
against the chicago bears at soldier
field and the bears knowing
that the only way they've got a good
chance in this game is if they terrorize
drew brees
tremendous pressure especially
either without michael thomas or with a
damaged michael thomas for new orleans
that offensive line has to keep drew
brees clean on sunday in chicago
show me something richard higgins he
said it himself yesterday with obj out
he's in the starting lineup now well
richard you get what you want and now
you got to go out and prove it or you're
not going to be in the starting lineup
for long so we're wondering where the
football is going to go without obj
let's see what higgins can do with
jarvis landry and all the other weapons
in cleveland so rashard higgins show us
something this weekend
how can the fourth round draft choice in
show me something before steelers ravens
be lamar jackson shouldn't that be
shouldn't he be picked in the first
round
show me something lamar jackson you know
it it's a it's a
not entirely a fair narrative but you
have got to start playing great you know
against the teams
that are really tough opponents
especially in your division doesn't have
as you talked about earlier a lot of
experience against the pittsburgh
steelers but these are the kind of games
that lamar jackson has to rise to the
occasion of and i don't care if he's got
to run it 20 times they have to figure
out a game plan to beat the pittsburgh
steelers this week
the pressure is on lamar jackson
and you know peter i go back to that
kryptonite comment and it may not just
be a chiefs dynamic for the ravens it
may be a ultra elite opponent dynamic
for the ravens whether it's the titans
who had everything going their way in
the playoffs the steelers who almost
beat them last year without ben
roethlisberger in overtime the only
start lamar jackson has against the
steelers i think this is a much bigger
game for him than maybe even he realizes
all right let's finish round four show
me something nick foles quite simply if
you don't they may show you the bench i
don't know who else they have floating
around other mitchell trubisky but at
some point foles has to do something and
he he all almost beat the saints almost
beat the saints in the playoffs a couple
of years ago but for the al shawn
jeffrey drop maybe indeed the eagles
would have gotten past new orleans with
foals playing quarterback i think the
saints may remember that a little bit
and the and and foles has got to do
something to turn this offense around
because it really is languishing and
five and three could be coming and five
and four maybe around the corner with
the tennessee titans up next for the
bears
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports